ótimo é o ambiental extraordinário e
efetivamente não só cá quem está no
palco que tem esse espírito
veja também no público um espírito tento
perfeitamente enquadrado seja esta
simbiose é fantástica porque vim falar
daquilo que é o espírito do livro é
pensarmos na forma múltipla daquilo que
é a vida de cada um nós efetivamente
algo muito pessoal sentir-se livre
sempre livre que é diferente estar em
liberdade
completamente diferente é que o que nós
temos muitas vezes que é um desafio
constante sejam os pais amigos seres
humanos no seu global
nesta nesta aldeia global que hoje cada
vez mais a interação uns com os outros
percebemos a importância dessa mesma
liberdade no sentido daquilo que é o
nosso íntimo daquilo que é o meu eu o
meu céu foi introduzido e partilhado com
os outros e cada vez mais as
neurociências apresentamos isso este
campo do que ninguém queremos percorrer
para nos encontrarmos uns com os outros
porque efetivamente o meu significado
enquanto eu não existisse não esquecer o
outro e efetivamente esse trabalho que
nós fazemos constantemente porque no
percurso que enquanto espécie humana
nós temos uma infância e uma
adolescência enorme ainda bem que temos
por que ela permita não só uma
integração e desenvolvimento de sistemas
vitais questões neurológicas em drogas e
outras tantas
mas acima de tudo é a oportunidade para
que a comunidade da família possam
participar na construção desse espírito
livre e que de uma forma constante
organizada possamos ir crescendo e
desafia nos a nós próprios e em quanto
tempo deixamos um legado seja cultural e
que a cultura tem um papel fundamental
em ter sempre ficamos que tudo aquilo
que nós possamos transmitir vos uns aos
outros num quadro da ação dinâmicas de
aprendizagem brincadeira de jogo de
fetos carinho se vão os criando camadas
que nos permitem ir agregando sabedoria
e conhecimento e competências que os
levam depois para a escola com as
empresas para as organizações para a
vida e nesse campo de atuação que tudo
começa aqui e tudo começa aqui quando
nós vamos dando liberdade e vamos
criando
oportunidade ordenados de experiência e
experienciar desenvolvermos sentindo
efetivamente os nossos limites e aqui
começamos a sentir que efetivamente é a
nossa relação em nossa gestão do próprio
risco dos medos tudo isso se enquadra
neste campo e nesta fase e nesta fase e
podem dizer sim mas há pessoas que têm
um espírito livre tem o seu espírito
estiveram contingências muito complexas
na sua infância é verdade mas nesse
quadro de competências muito complexos
tiveram oportunidade para testar os seus
limites gerir os seus eu sou o seu
processo de risco em nossa gestão do
risco ela parte muito do nosso eu e as
minhas limitações do forma como
estrutura o meu corpo pronto ambiente
onde estou e nesta relação nessa
interação constante entre o meu eu o
outro e o ambiente onde eu estou e vou
construindo e vou balizando os meus
medos passando à fase seguinte sempre
assim e vou experimentando aumentando e
é interessante verificar que às vezes
não é preciso ser o pai ou a mãe mas
pode ser o professor pode ser um amigo
pode ser toda a comunidade
um provérbio africano diz que tá educar
uma criança desmaiou idéia ao da
inesting e global
não podemos esquecer isso e ela se é
global e transcultural e grande grande
questão que se coloca aqui que não vai
permitir dar o salto é a questão da
aprendizagem do conhecimento no exílio
movimentaram procurar os nossos jovens
saberem mais tantos outros que existem
tudo que existe neste quadro global
mundial é que se pretende
às vezes damos manhã fazem norma que a
sociedade efetivamente se sabe o que é
do nosso entender como funcionará o que
doem nós entendo como bem estar
algumas almas mais insatisfeitas e nós
temos aqui uma série delas que acima das
críticas também do do frio e que a
insatisfação é aquela relação entre a
zona de conforto ea zona que imprime
taram aguentar e construir a minha vida
mas o conforto está constantemente a ser
pressionada e essa é também uma das
posições que o frio espírito coloca
constantemente coloca constantemente nas
equipas como trabalha seja liderar ou
seja questões de herança por exemplo
muitas
vamos ficar aqui alguns saber acabam
porteiro uma dimensão maior quando nós
ensinamos o caminho que possa possa ser
construído e possa ser feito porque nós
que ninguém portanto tudo é que o
percurso em faces vem tudo seja
estruturalmente organizado tudo bem mas
em cima do desafiantes desafiantes minha
experiência durante anos 50 anos de vida
mas acima de tudo aquilo que foi
aprender a trabalhar com centenas de
pessoas principalmente os jovens nestas
áreas e viu crescer 17 anos muitas vezes
com limitações na área da educação
especial e psicomotricista nos toques
1800 2000 seus filhos aqui uma
construção constante interação que nós
fazemos uns com os outros e pode
desafiar o colega do lado
é virar o teto ea partir daqui surgir
uma série de idéias fazendo networking
como nós fizemos construírem os desafios
constantes uma aprendizagem permanente e
essa aprendizagem permanente deve estar
constantemente estimulada seja por quem
a pessoa por quem nos ama primeiro se o
amalthea em tempo de natal tem um valor
é construído é incluir este este quadro
da ação deve permitir acima de tudo para
que esse argumento da dar se no espírito
livre o espetáculo envolve na gratidão é
esta uma das ações que foi foi
desenvolvida uma das questões que eu
coloquei mas por que ir para a bolívia
fazer isto eu mesmo assim eu já subi
muito em você já sabe muito bem muito
tempo dar mas acima de tudo dar certo é
uma interação constante uma gratidão
permanece que nos faz ser anunciar se
alguma característica que disse num
espírito livro é uma espécie de gratidão
e uma certa felicidade de estar
constantemente evoluindo e essa alegria
muitas vezes não é compreendido o outro
mas que nos faz permanentemente pôr em
risco em trabalhar o risco de uma forma
organizada e acima tudo porque correr
riscos do que riscos
o risco é fundamentalmente um motor da
evolução um cantor de emoção quando eu
construí e nós já falamos escolas que já
estiveram a falar
tocaram claramente isso pôr em causa
constantemente as fronteiras sem passar
por cima de ninguém tendo questões da
inflação se totalmente bem organizadas
mas acima de tudo por si em causa a si
próprio e essa constante dinâmica que
nós temos que ter a relação dos
questionários esta humildade nos
questionamos permite evoluir esta
acredita que dizemos está constantemente
desviados do nascimento até a morte
atenção às questões relacionadas com
espaços específicos de juventude para
fazer isto é é a criação mais e de 41
dias e neurológico nós temos na
estruturação quadro da potência da
aprendizagem mesmas faixas ao longo da
vida mas ao longo da vida com uma com
uma com algo gratificante que é a
experiência que a experiência movimento
que há que ter um dos tons relacionadas
com o exercício físico e nutrição
cuidados que devemos ter com os próprios
nos permite manter níveis ideais de
atividade de interação com o meio mas
acima tudo tudo este quadro da ação que
parece desafiar unifica a própria vida é
acima de tudo é que os da vida e é isso
que devemos ter bem problema de uma
forma constante na construção quando eu
procuro é diversidade cultural e procuro
que esse indivíduo vai agregando camadas
de experiências não estou a fazer mais
do que a dar a oportunidade de aprender
mais e perceber que há 11 wu é moda
global com diferentes formas de atuação
com respeito extraordinário do outro lhe
permitem em tributadas decentes graus de
liberdade a forma começa a ser dado é
entendida em diferentes pontos do globo
e como é que eu posso contribuir
enquanto ser humano não pegam um
construto global e esta construção um
crime pois olharam e seguir um caminho
muito claro tem muito claro em relação
aquilo que é a percepção daquilo que eu
quero fazer muitas vezes aquilo que eu
quero fazer não consegue ser
interpretado com os outros não consegue
ser porque é algo muito próprio
é isto encaminhamos para um quadro
específico de autodeterminação à
autodeterminação é fundamentalmente eu
saber escolher
no futuro sabendo que o no propósito é
meu e efetivamente um construto de
relação com os outros
tenho bem definido e cbs esse quadro
isto está estudado é que estão há uma
teoria que afirma terminação quando
tiverem tempo passei por lá e dê uma
olhada e vão ver a importância da
cultura a importância da estruturação do
indivíduo enquanto é ser um global e de
relação com os outros e como é que se
constrói mas acima de tudo uma vontade
clara daquilo que eu quero fazer
então escolha aqui o que eu quero fazer
eu sei que este é o mundo pelo menos por
agora que essa outra grande vantagem
pelo menos por agora é a mutação é tão
constante que no fundo acaba de saber
que dentro de dias de atraso não ter
tanto significado extra ter memória eo
legado pra mim possa passar os outros
essa experiência seja aquilo que eu vivo
hoje imprime transformar o mundo como
idéia deve permitir olhar as partes
daquilo que eu pretendo percorrer entre
petálas sérgio num quadro de topo uma
parcela de início em um tremendo mais é
que um resíduo três vezes a dificuldade
um do espírito ser livre é conseguir
interpretar o caminho quero fazer sempre
para onde vai esse é o grande desafio a
todas as aprendizagens nós fazemos desde
a infância até o momento em que nós
estamos todos nós aqui sabemos quando é
que vamos saber o que efetivamente
conseguimos passar do ponto a ao ponto b
é o grande e ficam os clocks e para isso
nós temos que ter um conjunto -
fundamentais de aprendizagem e
conhecimento e para poder enfrentar o
desconhecido
o desafio de interpretar o desconhecido
é para um espírito livre o maior desafio
um hospital é livre seguro e que se
pensa que eu não estava no seguro sofreu
sua zona de conforto o desconhecido não
deve ter infectado deve ser tímido e que
é a grande diferença
agora transformar os jovens porque eu
sinto que tudo tem que fazer
implica muito trabalho obviamente
funcionar a pressionar constantemente os
funcionários constantemente e que ele
era coisa maior que eu tenho que fazer é
mudar e mudar com as pernas e estimular
constante que de vez mais evidente
o cinto do lado a lado estava uma
empresa tem que ter que evoluir se tens
a tua vida tem estacionamento
transformá-la
mas como é que eu faço é muito fácil não
faz sozinho nunca o faço sozinho então
não faz sozinho aqui dimensões relação
emocional de relação social que tem
estar bem preparado em termos de
ferramentas bem desenvolvidas e aqui
entramos nos campos de quem ele era quem
acompanha quem é referência
acho que não é de ser referência para os
outros
a interação em participar constantemente
uma forma organizada
naquilo que é o fazer a diferença ora
muito bonito fazer a diferença poderia
acontecer em 2060 agora na prática na
prática está em buscar é que o que é os
nossos parceiros neoci estado muitas
vezes nossos medos e única forma de
combater os mesmos acontecimento o
conhecimento e interpretação desse
conhecimento alunos de diferentes formas
está na hora seja qual for a relação que
nós fazemos trabalhar muito com cartões
criaram o grandioso é transformar são
todas elas fazem parte daquilo que é o
espírito olímpico
se pensarem aquela pessoa que vocês
interpretaram como sendo a pessoa mais
livre
diariamente fantástica inspiradora e que
quer ter quatro serviria de exemplo ver
que está lá todo este conjunto - estão
lá
essa é uma característica biológica
social 5 biológico e até espiritual até
espiritual
se eu quiser eu quiser ver o todo
se eu quiser ver o todo eu tenho que
claramente construir aquelas parcelas
todas obter esta visão a dizem só para
os visionários e só posicionados dentro
de um visionário tá um ser humano sem
medo sem dúvidas mas que se atreveu a
pensar um pouco mais estruturado é mais
tranquilo gosto bem mas é esse
atrevimento nós queremos porque porque
efetivamente nós começamos a pensar em
termos históricos
estou isso foi construído à base de
atendimento
esta ilha foi tudo toda a urgência que
nós temos hoje que o futuro é base do
atendimento e ea constância das mudanças
faz com esse atendimento
mas para poder ler todo o curso nós
queremos fazer é não ver as parcelas
então quando não teve só consigo ver uma
parcela como é que eu faço ou à procura
de outra pessoa possa mostrar a outra
parcela até com julgar este caso e que a
interação social é fundamental e
entramos numa relação muito importante
dentro do espírito livre que é a
gratidão ea relação com o outro é
fundamental e não encontrou ninguém
dentro deste espírito livre que não
tenha uma relação de forte e nem
capacidade ea competência de se
relacionar com os outros rapidamento é
uma característica desse serviço o que é
fantástico isso pode ser trabalhado e
entre o santa não muito grande prazer
poder interagir mas não encontram um
frio espírito seja fechado organizado no
seu eu sem se abrir o mundo acontece a
questão da espiritualidade eu eu
pretendo fundamental num quadro nação se
fico é e muitas vezes não damos
importância entretanto se ficar que nos
últimas tendências na opção é colocar o
quadro durante a digestão e espiritual a
começar por ser um mero uma força muito
grande
cada vez mais temos referências de num
quadro da espiritualidade que vem
digamos se organizar e organizar tudo o
quadro da lógica é do rigor e da
estruturação que muitas vezes é e
grandes organizações têm cada vez mais
procuram pessoas que sejam usadas que
são corajosas que sejam bonitas por
dentro e por fora que façam a diferença
e consigam construir acima de tudo um eu
que seja útil para o outro é que o
sentido é fundamental
não não entra em conflito com o quanto
está um dedo do meu eu ser melhor o
nosso hotel não é isso que está em causa
mas é o meu eu como o momento imprimir
ter uma paixão encontrar num é desculpa
ok no fundo nós construímos tudo esta
relação um quadro daquilo que é que nós
já vimos em todas as explicações nós
temos de forma se identificam as pessoas
que é uma paixão smov constantemente
imóveis acima tudo para levar um
treinado ponto ninguém salta de 15 são
do conforto para uma ou outra que não é
tão confortável sem uma paixão sem uma
referência clara e essa festa é clara e
nós temos que ensinar às nossas crianças
muito cedo é perceber o que é se
apaixonar com o projeto ir atrás de eu
ir atrás daquilo que faz mover e que o
faz manter acordado e ficado em uma
situação muito para o que será o seu
sonho em cima de tudo agradecer
agradecer efetivamente a presença do
outro a relação com o outro e essa
gratidão acaba o terceiro um ponto toque
permite abrir uma série de portas é
aquela relação com o stress no olhar com
os pais por exemplo nas concessões mais
recentes em termos das neurociências
identificação dos neurônios pele como
faz relacionaram escusou se conectaram
uns com os outros e que os permite
identificar e criar uma rede nacional
ampla estruturada e que nós todos com
treinando mundo melhor organizado mais
gratificante mais feliz por isso é que
eu acredito que é possível construir um
espírito livre agora num quadro
específico que cada um se identificar e
conseguir um espaço em que o jovem
alguém consiga um caminhão de organizar
esse mundo um espaço em que o indivíduo
já está em uma fase mais avançada da sua
vida começa a organizar em questionar
uma série de padrões daquilo que é o seu
entendimento da sua segurança do seu
espaço daquilo que eu pretendo fazer com
base sempre um sonho uma paixão e uma
determinação que vem centro dentro mas
que precisa da ajuda todos muito
obrigado
[Aplausos]